welcome to yet one more session and
welcome back Pastor Randy thank you
please lead us in a water of prayer
before we do this Our Father in heaven
in James 1 verse 5 the Bible says if any
of you lack wisdom let him ask of god
father I surely lack it I ask you to
grant that wisdom to my brother and to
me May answer according to thus say the
Lord that your name may be glorified and
those listening blessed in Jesus name I
pray amen
amen which Bible books would you
recommend for somebody who wants to
start memorizing the Bible oh
immediately I recommend the Gospel of
John let me tell you why I recommend
John let's go to John chapter 20 we read
verses 203 and 31 now my favorite Bible
book is Genesis but I always recommend
John as the book to begin your
memorization Journey now listen to what
John says John Chapter 20: 30 and 31
he's giving us the reason why he wrote
his book and truly Jesus did many the
signs in the presence of his disciples
which are not written in this book okay
let's pause right there and Jesus did
many other signs or miracles in the
presence of his disciples so they saw
which are are not written in this book
many John said keep
reading but these are written now pause
in other words he carefully selected
from all the Miracles he saw Christ do
he selected some very carefully now why
here's why okay this were written to you
that may that you may believe that Jesus
is the Christ the son of God and that
beling you may life in his name yes so
John is saying I saw Jesus Christ do a
lot of things now all of them were good
Jesus never did anything bad but even
though they were all good John looked at
all the good things Christ did and the
Miracles and he chose about seven of
them there's one Miracle after Christ
Rose there's seven before he rose and he
said he included this in his book if you
study these if you read my book which
was carefully written it will point you
to Christ and eternal life and so while
all the Bible is designed to do that but
John is explicit in the reason why he
wrote so is Luke by the way in act Luke
chapter 1 the first four verses and the
book of Acts chapter 1 the first few
verses and so I recommend John it's a
it's also written by the disciple
closest to Christ who was John he lived
the longest and it was he to whom Christ
appeared and gave the Book of Revelation
and so I recomend and John begin his
gospel then his Epistles 1 2 and third
John of course he also wrote the Book of
Revelation
M how can one get rid of addictions such
as pornography and masturbation some
weaknesses are not easily overcome they
are all conquerable but some are a
greater challenge than others now
remember that God took 40 years to
changeed Moses's mindset he had grown up
in Egypt he was a graduate of the
Egyptian University the the Bible says
he was mighty in word and deed acts 7:22
Moses was steeped in Egyptian education
God took 40 years to change that man to
get him ready to lead the Israelites for
another 40 years it may take a while for
you to ACC but you must believe you can
conquer conquest of any weakness begins
with the surrender of the will to God it
includes removing yourself from
circumstances that make it easy to fall
into that trap but the first is give
this to God so that he controls it
recommit your life to him daily you may
also need to seek professional help
there's nothing wrong with professional
help because God gives wisdom to all
kinds of people you may need to seek
professional help but I recommend
Christian professionals to give you
counseling but whatever your weakness is
whether it's fornication masturbation
whatever it is it is conquerable because
the Bible says now unto him that is able
ble to keep you from falling Jude verse
24 and so yes that's what I recommend
all right is it right to kiss before
marriage 1 Corinthians 10:31 whether
therefore you eat or drink or whatsoever
you do do all to the glory of God the
question is why are you kissing what's
the spiritual value do you pray first
what can it lead to you understand can a
lead to be the human being is heavily
affected by touch
you want to hold her hands why are you
keeping her from a ditch you're holding
hands now you want to kiss what's next
after kiss you see a tight Embrace
what's next after that we must keep our
eyes on what an action can lead to and
so we recommend the spiritual counselors
no kissing it isn't spiritually
necessary to
kiss husband and wife yes kiss all you
want but because if it leads to
something else it's fine with God are
you with me but two single unmarried
people kissing the why are you
kissing why and did you pray first can
you include God in that activity simple
questions to ask kissing is designed to
fulfill sensual desires not spiritual
needs yeah and I believe on the same
line it would be helpful to
differentiate between the kissing that
goes around today and what the Bible
says
absolutely yes mhm it is not what we
consider a kiss to today mhm all right
is it right for a but by the way greet
one another with a holy kiss is not a
command so if you don't do it you
haven't sinned because some people take
this holy kiss too far so to avoid
trouble you just don't do it all right
okay is it right for a Christian to go
for therapy sessions nothing wrong with
it as I said earlier in the previous
question God gives wisdom to all kinds
of people not just his people and so we
benefit from their wisdom but again I
recommend a Christian counil
if not a 7day Adventist uh research the
person's background carefully so you go
and receive counseling from someone who
has spiritual
values right and the next one is the
animal kingdom displays many sinful
traits for an instance fighting for food
and space is this a result of sin
absolutely the result of
sin plants have thorns because of sin
you Revelation not Revelation J 3 thorns
and thistles shall it Break Forth unto
thee and thou shalt eat the herb of the
field Genesis 3:17 yes the behavior of
animals the violence in the animal
kingdom there's violence even in plants
there's some plants that eat little
animals mhm they trap them and they
dissolve them yes they're plants that
feed on little animals like rodents and
Beatles and whatever else that is all
the result of sin and When sin is
removed the entire system goes back to
what it's supposed to
be by the the way animals don't sin they
suffer from the consequence of what Adam
did they're not charged with sin so in
the New World God won't resurrect
animals he resurrects people because he
didn't die to save animals he died to
save us he'll just make brand new
animals but he resurrects the righteous
dead okay is the seventh day Sabbath a
ceremonial Sabbath or was it abolished
on the cross the ceremonial system with
all its details was given in the
wilderness not as I said all his detail
there were a few that were practiced
before this the the Wilderness
wanderings of the
Israelites the Sabbath is announced
before there was sin before there was a
sacrificial system so it cannot be a
ceremonial activity the Sabbath is one
of God's original Ten Commandments
required of us to observe according to
God's command and so it is not a
ceremonial Sabbath it will be observed
in a new world where there will be no
ceremonial activities as was practi I in
the wilderness by the Israelites the
Sabbath is one of the Ten Commandments
part of the moral law not a ceremonial
day okay people will do anything to get
away from the Sabbath they'll do
anything they'll find any excuse to
avoid it's astonishing the attacks that
that one commandment receives that one
commandment remember the Sabbath day to
keep it holy no one attacks the other
night they always attack that one with
no evidence at all from scripture that
it has been changed yeah okay in the Ten
Commandments God refers to himself in
the first person sometimes in the third
person why is that so is this a style of
writing that practiced by the the
prophets to whom God gave Revelations
sometimes first person sometimes third
person I don't think there's any
theological significance it's just a
style of writing for instance there are
poetic expressions in the Bible just a
style of writing Psalm 33:6 by the word
of the Lord where the heavens made and
all the hosts of them by the breath of
his mouth that's Hebrew parallelism the
first statement says exactly what the
second statement says it's just a style
of writing all right m is Sunday a holy
day because Jesus no matter what the
rest of question is it is not a holy day
but the rest of it says because Christ
Rose I am glad Christ Rose because a
dead Jesus cannot save you but nowhere
in the Bible are we told to celebrate
his day of Resurrection as a holy day
the Bible does never says God blessed
the day on which Christ Rose he blessed
the day on which Christ rested after he
created and Christ himself blessed that
day by the way because he's the Creator
the Bible does not call upon us my
listening friends to observe the day on
which Christ Rose or the day on which he
was crucified which people call Good
Friday we're called to celebrate the Day
on which he rested and that is the
seventh day Sabbath
okay why are most of God's Remnant
churches preaching smooth messages oh
are they preaching smooth messages well
I don't know what they all preach but
you know there's there's a we live we're
living in the last days which are very
perilous times we ought to be very
direct not necessarily harsh but direct
people need to understand there's a
judgment coming when I say judgment I
mean an activity in which God will wipe
out Sinners who have hard
hardheaded stubbornly resisted the
conviction of the spirit they will be
destroyed by God not accidentally
deliberately
by God the way he deliberately destroyed
sod and Gomorrah and the ancient world
in the days of Noah people need to know
that they need to know that there's a
God who loves but there's a God who gets
angry we need to know there's a God of
Mercy there's a god of wrath they need
to be told that we love to hear God is
love love love love love and we see God
as an ancient old senile grandfather no
no no no no we serve a God who gets
angry it's also an expression of love so
people need to know directly look you
need to give up your sins or you will be
l lost and when God destroyed the sinner
it will be horrible and excruciating
that's one reason he delays and delays
because he knows it will be so horrible
and so my direct message is let's put
away sin by the power of the indwelling
spirit because your only problem is sin
that's the only problem God has with us
and so smooth messages are not for is
not what people need not now at any
other the time in history we need direct
so people cannot say what did he say I
said get sin out of your
life leave that relationship in which
you're in and you're not married that's
what I said I said remember the Sabbath
there I said Return to tithe I said stop
stealing I said stop cheating on your
taxes I said stop that sin will take you
to hell you can stop by the power of God
direct smooth messages only benefit
Satan yeah and it's God's call upon the
remnant people to give the trumpet the
certain give the trumpet a certain sound
mhm
H why is adultery the only ground for
divorce that's what the Bible gives you
see that's the reason why now the church
adds a few of reasons but the Bible's
single reason is adultery that's what
the Bible says that's that's that's
that's God's choice okay is it advisable
for sth day Adventists to work in non
seventh day organizations especially if
those environments uh they don't
practice Christian rules Sly adst can't
simply keep to themselves they have a
message to give they have a life to
demonstrate Daniel worked in an
environment that was not Hebrew when he
worked for Nebuchadnezzar then he worked
for Darius Joseph worked for Pharaoh in
an environment that was paganistic God
needs his people in environments where
the unbeliever can see so Pharaoh got to
know God somehow because of Joseph
Nebuchadnezzar came ultimately to accept
God because of Daniel
and so yes God needs his people in
environments that are not Christian but
he puts them there carefully he does not
put many he selects them carefully those
who can withstand the negative
influences that they will encounter not
everybody specially chosen people he
selects to put them in those those
environments but yes God needs people in
non-Christian environment so that the
non-Christian the unbeliever may see
what it is like to be a Bible believer
Christian all right or Bible believing
sever the Adventists let me be precise
okay can a person still be saved who has
divorced and remarried more than once
anyone who repents will be saved anyone
who repents will be but things need to
be made right when you realize God's
plan was one wife one husband all the
way back to Adam and Eve what you need
to do is you need to cease physical
interaction with the other wives and
commit get yourself to the first one you
married that's your wife Abraham had a
relationship with Hagar Hagar was not
recognized by God as Abraham's wife only
Sarah was recognized by God as Abraham's
wife that has been made very clear you
can marry a thousand people which one
does God recognize the first one because
it's one man one woman what that man has
to do is to cease this conjugal
interaction with the others explain to
them why he's doing it he's become a
child of God he has to follow God's
leading but he cannot abandon them
because they're not responsible for the
situation he focuses on one that's the
first one and he takes care of the
others okay but you can't be practicing
polygamy knowing the truth and expect to
be saved Jesus has one wife not several
and that's the church all right and our
last question for tonight is I divorced
my husband due to infidelity MH is God's
will still for us to
reconcile or to stay
unmarried part two of it is is it sinful
to consider marrying somebody
else in Malachi 2:16 for the Lord God of
Israel sayith that he hateth putting
away God does not like divorce Jesus
told the Pharisees in Matthew 19 5 to8
Moses because of the hardness of your
heart suffered you to put away your
wives divorce is a result of sin
staying together is God's original plan
before sin let me say it again staying
together was God's original plan and God
wants us to pursue the ideal divorce was
permitted because of sin but it was
permitted and the Bible gives the limit
which is of course adultery now can
someone who divorced reconcile yes
because when God put Adam out of the
garden the Hebrew word also means
divorce but through Christ we can be
reconcil back to God you see through
through Christ so God believes in
reconciliation but as the person who
asked the question I think it's a lady
if she divorced because the husband
broke the marriage's vows through
adultery then she is free and our church
teaches that to
remarry but if he wants to reconcile and
she's open to that yes because Calvary
is constant proof God loves
reconciliation but if she doesn't she
has not sinned and we can't judge her
because we're not in her shoes because
the Bible permits her to to to to to
separate because the vow was broken but
ideally if reconciliation can take place
that's good but if she decides to
remarry someone else she has not
sinned or if he decides if he was
innocent the innocent person can Remar
okay all right that brings us to the end
okay let let's tell our listeners that
you may not have heard your question
answered and it's probably causing some
little disappointment we go through the
questions carefully and decide which
questions if we an them can be of
Maximum benefit to everyone who's
listening and not simply satisfying an
individual uh desire which is fine and
legitimate don't misunderstand us but
we're also trying to speak to Non sth
day Adventists and we want to try
through this session to explain to them
what adventism is and so we keep these
things in mind as we select the
questions to answer we're not picking on
you if your question wasn't answered but
we pray we go through them and we say
okay this one not that one or not now at
another session so try to understand
every question cannot be dealt with but
continue sending your questions and
wherever you are on this round girth may
the Lord bless you thank you for your
interest in his word and again live by
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of God what am I referring to the
Bible the Old and the new and we both
say from our hearts God bless BL you
make you a blessing to others and may
God put a double blessing on your
children amen pray for us Pastor dear
heavenly father may your name be
glorified and thank you for what you
have enabled us to share this evening we
continue to pray a blessing upon your
people those who are searching for truth
oh God that you will lead them to
yourself give out your power and wisdom
through the inspiration of the Holy
Spirit enable each one of us to
understand you better to love you to
obey you and to be prepared for your
Everlasting Kingdom thank you for Pastor
Randy kit I pray a blessing upon him and
his ministry thank you for the equipment
we have used and the church we have used
to do this ministry tonight blessing
upon this church and your people here
may you go with each one of us now and
remember us in the day of your coming
for we pray in Jesus name amen amen amen
but